esta ha sido una decisión celebrada en
Ucrania que lleva meses pidiendo que se
cree una corte especial para juzgar los
crímenes de guerra especialmente El
crimen de agresión cometido por Rusia en
este país Ellos dicen que no solamente
es necesaria la victoria sino que
también hay que llevar a la justicia a
los agresores y a los que ordenaron esta
agresión no solamente el presidente
Vladimir Putin sino todos los que lo
rodearon y han estado con él tomando las
decisiones importantes de esta invasión
que comenzó el 24 de febrero con unas
consecuencias catastróficas para tanto
Ucrania pero también para los soldados
rusos que han participado en esta guerra
ellos aseguran que al Rusia no estar no
ser firmante del tratado de la corte
criminal internacional no puede ser
juzgado allí por el por el delito de
agresión pero también dice que cualquier
decisión cualquier corte que se cree en
el contexto de las Naciones Unidas va a
ser vetado por Rusia que tiene un puesto
en el consejo de seguridad de las
Naciones Unidas Así que se busca crear
un tribunal especial aparte para que
lleve a cabo estos juicios esto ha sido
respaldado no solamente por Francia que
lo respaldo hoy sino también por los
ministros de la organización para la
seguridad y la cooperación de Europa o
sé que están reunidos en Polonia y con
excepción de Rusia que hace parte de
ellas pero no está presente han
asegurado que también apoyan la decisión
de este tribunal cuyos detalles pues se
tendrán que ir analizando en el futuro